ladies and gentlemen boys and girls my
name's Greg Albert no I'm Joan I'm free
I am I am I was on my way to the gym I
was right to the parking lot I was like
7:30 and I am on time there's gonna be a
good day start your morning right then I
found out this is dropping and I was
like okay let's turn back around and
let's shoot this first and get it up on
YouTube let's watch the lego movie - the
second part official trailer numero dos
according to Warner Brothers before we
go into that obligatory shout out for
ourselves we are on the Stardust app
ladies and gentlemen that's right we're
part of that community thank you because
we have just passed 7.5 k followers
hoorah
over there we do 30 second reaction
reviews for any film TV show or trailer
post daily choking on my shake I'm
supposed to meet my post-workout shake
those daily on there yep three download
free to use let's get to this
[Music]
[Laughter]
believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
messed up
[Music]
a lot of fun himself
[Music]
[Laughter]
100% certain what it was about this
specific trailer as opposed to the other
one but this one brought me more of what
I actually wanted the movie to be
remember the first trailer for part 2 it
was like yeah but they're watching this
one I'm like this actually looks just as
delightful as the first one in a lot of
ways it's like the first trailer I kind
of had the same response too and I think
this is getting closer to the tone that
I sort of associated with the original
lego movie I mean this didn't pummel me
with like things that I think are gonna
be brilliant just yet but it definitely
brought me back to like okay this is
kind of an intriguing place to start
from like the world's a wasteland and
like Mad Max style and it makes wonder
like poke fun in itself at the very top
what everything was awesome
you know everything is brief which I
don't know if they're it's intentional
if that's like a commentary on how
sequels are usually done where the part
twos are usually a lot darker it's kind
of what I took it out I don't know it's
open to interpretation or maybe it's
just a funny joke they had at the top of
it to set up this new premise and of
course you know gosh our main female
character Lucy wyldstyle has to get
rescued by a man oh yeah I mean how
archaic man gosh we just do not evolve
not even an animation it should be all
women rescuing her but she doesn't need
rescued even it was part of the planning
capture and to get all the other female
characters there to join her team that's
the true story that would have been the
better version right there I love this
Rosie comes up Rex
dangerous dangerous minutes big up that
though it was a Chris Pratt maybe part
of himself especially the galaxy one the
rapture its Chris for having fun which I
love man it's that's pretty cool that
he's willing to do that you know he does
play all these different types of
characters but they all do have the same
Chris Pratt personality will be fun I
mean I always enjoyed
opportunities to lampoon you know the
reality I mean one thing that is
probably hard to communicate in the
trailers for I think for any of these
Lego movies that they've done I haven't
seen Ninjago but I remember the first
one and Lego Batman had it they all have
a big heart they don't really ever
communicate that in their trailers
they're always saying you want the crazy
animation the fun's a meme it I feel
like there's a lot of kinetic energy and
like funny bits that yeah I'm just from
for a trailer like this and yeah the the
heart seems to come out in a more
complex way at least as of like the
first lego movie like that yeah part of
what that movie is getting to it the
core are a little hard to get across in
a bite-size package you know I'm
wondering what the arc is though for
Emmet it seems like it's gonna be like a
very similar arc that he had in the
first one er yeah I kind of got a
similar vibe and that's the biggest
question mark for me now because I think
they have a good writing team I looked
it up and it's like Lord and Miller are
on the script as well as Raphael
bob-waksberg who's the showrunner Bojack
horseman and stuff which is the show
that has a lot of like emotional grit as
well as you know for any zaniness I
think there's another writer from Cloudy
with a Chance of Meatballs I wonder if
that combination can kind of come
together with something that's a bit
more than what you'd expect from a lego
sequel cuz right now I'm like I like
this trailer I liked it more than the
first trailer it's got me more excited
but yeah I still don't have that sense
of like what's gonna make this great
like the first lego movie was friggin
great I'm wondering if the experience
might be you know tamper down a little
bit because the fact that we've had two
other Lego movies in between the first
one was so magical and then by the time
even by the time you get around to like
Lego Batman which is very enjoyable and
some people really love that movie I
just liked it and love it and enjoy
ready to perform so well I'm wondering
is that gonna affect the overall
reaction to this movie and the box
office performance too because then jogo
didn't do so well maybe going back to
lego movie the original might you know
cause people to come back I feel like
three will do fine and you know ya know
I don't I don't have any question
that'll make at least a decent amount of
money I think that yeah is the kind of
critical factor cuz a lot of people
started to say after Ninjago the lego
formula it needs more stuff than just
what they have right now
because after you've seen Lego and
you've seen Batman and you've seen
Ninjago you kind of get how they do it
and I feel like we've kind of felt the
weight of those diminishing returns
because it's like yeah I love the lego
movie
I like the Lego Batman movie and I
wasn't really that interested in you
know so I feel like that's the one kind
of thing they face going forward is if
they want to keep these Lego movies
going they have to find a way to make it
so that it's not just that one tone that
they're known for yeah I think Lord and
Miller - especially with working on the
story for it because they seem very
passionate about the first story
especially with the way they tied it in
with you know the real life of Will
Ferrell at the end I'm wondering - are
they gonna do something like that at the
end of this movie they're gonna come out
at the end of the toy convention yeah so
many people there's gonna be this major
commentary on how it's the future and
everything has gone to hell because of
Trump being president yeah that's why
it's all bleak yeah or maybe they're
gonna break through Andy's house is
gonna be a Toy Story crossover cuz that
could totally work cuz Legos are toys
too and every single property known to
man is also licensed by Lego so that
could get super meta like a Buzz
Lightyear Lego city's like what is this
you know I appreciate you going with me
on that you've got developed 15 take it
on the road well this does look fun it
looks adorable what can you say before
we wrap this up I want to give a patient
a shout out to a man named Daniel
Gallacher listen Daniel according to our
patreon messages on October 25th you
sent me some messages here and then
October 26th I reply back to you with
about two and a half paragraphs worth of
material to work off of and you know
what I've noticed we are now all the way
to November 20th if I'm not mistaken you
have not replied back to me at all I
don't really know how I feel about that
I just want to make sure you stay
pledged so if you don't want to reply to
me totally cool or if you want to reply
in like an alternate method you know
like by increasing your pledge totally
cool that's the clearest way to do it
that sends a message for every time I
send you a message if you want to just
increase that pledge say okay yeah and
increasing exponentially by how many
words there are so the longer message
bigger increasing and I'm sorry I didn't
finish better call Saul yet too busy re
watching that 70 show lately
and playing Red Dead Redemption to keep
your eye on what's important yeah man
four hours at Red Dead Redemption two at
night you make point zero two percent
progress on that game alright guys well
thanks for tuning and you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation and click
that notification valve down low to
follow us and start us up free to use
for yeah you know is that